ce devait être le grand projet de la
ville de fleury dans l'aude la bulle
d'eau en 1988
la commune se dote d'un observatoire
sous marins l'objectif faire plonger les
touristes au coeur d'un monde aquatiques
fleury d'aude sera bientôt la première
ville d'europe à être équipée d'un
observatoire sous marins
pourtant malgré sa construction le site
n'a jamais accueilli un seul visiteur
c'est un flop total en cause notamment
des études bâclé ou encore des défauts
de construction aujourd'hui
la bulle est toujours coincé dans son
corset de béton elle refuse de devenir
observatoire les vitres se fendille le
sable colle aux parois rien à voir le
bâtiment devient alors un véritable
gouffre financier pour la commune des
entreprises attendent d'être payés
résultat les dettes s'accumulent les
habitants de fleury sont alors en
première ligne et voient leurs impôts
locaux explosé
qui a été pris on assiste d'arrivée mais
l'application on va voir de près
pour yves être majoré on est tenu de
payer en 1999 même onze ans après le
lancement de la bulle d'eau les
habitants de fleury continue de mettre
la main à la poche
il reste à payer une créance car acheter
le conseil général
ao d'aménagement qui était le maître
d'ouvragé délégué c'est une classe de 15
millions de francs en plus ses intérêts
de 15 millions de frênes et ils restent
dues aux entreprises 10 millions de
francs entre annie resterait 25 à 28
millions de frênes à prier aujourd'hui
encore aujourd'hui la dette et payer
pour les habitants de fleury après
trente ans de procédures judiciaires et
9 millions d'euros dépensés selon la
mairie la bulle d'eau va enfin être
démentie
[Musique]